[Music]
thank you
and falling fast through the trees
tripping over the pines and the leaves
and
[Music]
it feels like we're both choking to
breathing holding tied to a false memory
I'm
[Music]
shooting degrees
I wish that we could make a change give
up The Ghost and walk away show
ourselves that we can do without it
[Music]
once you know better
once you know better time
foreign
[Music]
me
now we know there's too much to lose
[Music]
walk away
show ourselves
you are
foreign
[Music]
hey y'all I really hope you dug that
video it was really fun to put together
and to perform uh real quickly I just
wanted to give a shout out to flowtoys
for sponsoring this video and giving me
a reason both to go out and flow every
month as well as to play around with
those cool post-production Trails if
you're interested in grabbing a set of
those pod POI with HBC or excuse me FBC
tethers you can do that by heading on
over to flowtoys.com and using my
special promo code drexfactor 2023 yes
indeed it has changed for the new year
that will get you a discount on your
order and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins thank you once again to
flowtoys for sponsoring this kind of
content from me and speaking of thank
yous big thanks to the uh to the Friends
of the channel thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca
flow fests flow toys juggling calling
power Terra light toys and Ultra POI for
supporting myself this Channel and the
videos on it you can learn more about
all these amazing companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and
special thanks to the non-business
Friends of the channel That is Lane
machinsky and Becca becklonen thank you
both so very much for your support from
my work and my mission and finally this
video would not be possible were it not
for the kind support of all of these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they and the
people who sit down in the description
help to make all the videos on this
channel possible so thank you one and
all for your very generous support and
if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter but you'd like to
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission so go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to see more flow videos
from me I will link to a playlist of
other flow videos that I've done down in
the description as well as up here on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video based upon
your past viewing habits so maybe check
that out as well thanks so much for
watching make sure to subscribe and I
will see with a new video about POI and
flow Arts real soon take care and have a
good one peace